like my mom always says patch cat on him
but you put your cat at him
that's your money maker that's my money
maker as long as she don't catch a cold
as long as she stay right she's
protected everything in my life is all
right she makes me money
so pat your cat out
all right diamond
diamond where'd you grow up where are
you from my name big diamond you're a
big diamond too many diamonds there's a
lot of diamonds yes
i grew up in merida mississippi
tell me about your family growing up
um
big family
square family hard-working working
i'm like the black sheep of my family
you're the black sheep
yeah
i'm the bad one
the only one that's been in prison
the only one that has been in and out of
jail the only one that does drugs
the only one that
prostitutes
the only one that actually just [ __ ] up
period
that's me
um
i'm 40 years old
i started
doing my life well living my life in a
bad way when i was about
14.
i was a stripper at 14. 14 yeah in
mississippi yeah they thought i was 18.
i looked apart
so i was good i was lucky on that part
but um
i was stripping for a little while
i stopped after they found out i was
only 14.
uh this girl that um liked me
she kind of
[ __ ] up and got me in trouble with
that
um because her dude asked her a question
and she accidentally told him in front
of somebody else and they told on me and
they got me fired
and um
basically
from there
i went to
working the streets of mississippi
and uh
it's so different from out here
the two lives are so different how is it
different mississippi then in
mississippi figueroa street you can work
in regular clothes
as long as you're standing here
on the track out there they know you
the police don't [ __ ] with you
and it's like
you don't have mufflers just riding
around looking looking look you're doing
uh jacking off to you and all that stuff
if they want they they wanna date you
they're gonna come up and they gonna
date you it's not a bunch of [ __ ]
like out here out here it's like
your [ __ ] riding past you well
how much
well i'll be back
or they just sit there and jack off i'm
like what the [ __ ]
it's totally different but it's faster
it's a faster life right here way faster
um and more dangerous
back home wasn't so dangerous
it was like okay country [ __ ] yeah
let's go do our thing
we're done these [ __ ] they want
to kidnap you rape you beat you
just dog you not all of them not all
not all trust me because i've met
some good ones
boy tell me about the good ones um i
still have one now to this day and i've
been knowing him for 10 years now
and
he picked me up
took me to his house
i dated him
and i've never gotten rid of him since
and i mean he was the perfect gentleman
he treated me like as if i was his woman
instead of a prostitute
and every time i see him
even if i don't date him or do anything
with him he still gives me money how
much money um with him it was four
hundred dollars
to date him by 2400 and we did our thing
but now it's like when i call him if i
need him for anything he'll come and
whatever i ask him for he'll give it to
me uh a couple of months ago i needed
600
i called him i was scared to call him
because it's like i just got to call him
a couple of days ago
but i really needed him and i'm like
okay you gonna bring me 600
i need it i told him what it's for
and he was like okay cool
i'm like okay cool
this [ __ ] is just okay with
everything i want
but it's like whatever i want he gives
it to me it's nice you guys have an
arrangement yeah
but it's not like uh we'll put this on
my [ __ ] bill you know what i'm saying
so he's just giving you money because he
likes you yeah you need some help and he
helps you out yeah
and then um but he understands what you
do yeah he does he doesn't ask you about
it
no
no no no no he doesn't um he knows what
life i mean he knows what i do you know
out there all he says is be protected
you know
when i call you just be available for me
cool
he never gets shells
yeah he has once he really did once
because i put another client before him
and he's like
i'll give you anything i'll give you
anything just you know
tell them to go away
i'm like i'm not going to do that you
know what i'm saying
it was another one of my regular clients
and i'm not gonna you know choose client
for client
if you're here first i'm gonna deal with
you first if you're not so be it but i'm
not gonna put one before the other one
um he didn't understand that he was like
well i pay you more money this time
if you're just going to tell them to go
i'm like i'm not going to do that i
don't care about you paying me more
money that's not the point
i treat my clients with respect the ones
that are my my my regulars
but like just a fly by [ __ ] that i just
jumped in the car with
it's like whatever you know i'm gonna
respect you to a certain extent i'm
gonna treat you the way you're supposed
to be treated but you're gonna respect
me and my boundaries and treat me where
i wanna be treated too
i don't get out there with the
shenanigans and the [ __ ] rare
exchange ain't no robbery i deal just
like that
i don't want to be treated
no different from
your sister your mother your grandmother
you know i'm saying as far as my respect
goes regardless to what i do
but um
is this the only kind of work you've
ever done
no i've had three jobs yeah three
regular jobs um i worked at cracker
barrel
in mississippi and i worked at um
what's the name of wendy's and shawnee's
so i worked at
little restaurant
tell me about the difference between
these two different lifestyles
um
a nine to five
i don't like listening to people it's
being told what to do and when to do it
or how to do it i don't like that i
don't like nobody over me authority over
me period never have liked it and
working at nine to five i have to listen
to my manager tell me when to come when
to go what to do what time this this
thing that
don't do that to me and then i have to
interact with people
and the way they
they work with the customer is always
right
that's not the case with me [ __ ]
customers always right in this game
i'm right
you're your own boss right so whatever i
say goes
even if you have a pimp
i've had one pimp and quite clearly i
will never in my life do that again
i don't see myself giving no [ __ ] my
money
i can't do that that [ __ ] me up
this man acted like he wanted to be my
man
at first
like boyfriend girlfriend and then it's
like he said he didn't have no girl all
that okay cool
i could deal with you all of a sudden
this [ __ ] come with three other
[ __ ]
and i'm like whoa then he said these are
my hoes i'm like huh
and then i go along with the program for
a little while and i'm like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] take all the money
at the end of the day
i got to go through him to get what i
want
i couldn't do that i was close that [ __ ]
then he working on their asses and [ __ ]
i'm like oh wait a minute i'm new here
so quite clearly i ain't got to ask for
me but quite clearly if you're whooping
they ass you gonna try with mine sooner
or later i'm out of here i ran off and
left
and uh i never looked back on that [ __ ]
you've been independent ever since ever
since i swear for god and there's no way
on god's green earth i will ever get a
pimp again so you make you keep all your
money i keep
are you saving money yeah i just bought
you cars you just bought two cars mm-hmm
good for you i do i do
i do something with myself besides my
drugs yes i use drugs you do
yeah crack cocaine i started off storing
powder
and then i moved to crack cocaine but
i'd rather
do the way i'm doing it
and survive than to do it away some
[ __ ] telling me to do it
and be one what i want still
i've talked to so many girls who said
you know they'll make a thousand dollars
a night but they're broke every night
yeah
that's that's [ __ ] true though what
are they spending it on
drugs uh
daily life like you know a roof over
your head clothes on your back food on
your table
if you got family and kids you still
gotta deal with that riggs nails shoes
exactly
wigs nail shoes all that it all comes
into play you can see this
no i don't [ __ ] with that
something dude
yeah
but the gambling
no i do scratchers
that's still gambling that's why i
haven't gone
scratching scratches in my habit
um
the streets are littered with scratched
lottery tickets yeah
basically
but um
the difference with out here also is
it's like
you never know which streets you're
going to turn on and get robbed
and rob us back home
i don't i haven't been robbed several
times have you yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy
for a [ __ ] to jump out the car
talk to you for a second whatever
try to date you get you in the car
and then take you around the corner and
rob you
and have been watching you the whole
time
[ __ ] did that to me he told me that he
had been watching me he knew i got money
but he couldn't find it on me he never
could find it on me he patted me down
took him maybe take my clothes off strip
button that kid took my shoes off shake
my shoes everything wigged everything
off
and he still couldn't find my money
toward the lining i'm a purse all that
no money
he went to the point to so far as to
want to stick his hand up in my side my
vagina and my butt to see if i hit my
money
but he still didn't get it
at the end of the day so he basically
he he
he did he got nothing at the end of the
day
but just the point that she was trying
to rob me
was so crazy and i see a lot of girls
out here that it happens more than once
and more often than some others
i'm like hell no you try to rob me again
but you're gonna get a rude awakening i
got something for the ass now
but
i'm 40 years old
i'm out here i'm still out here
on the street
i had stopped smoking for a while for a
long time um
not too long ago uh a dude of mine
passed away and i stopped smoking i just
started back
yeah i relapsed and um
i was doing good
i was doing good i was doing real good
um
i don't know what made me relapse though
so you you would go out and work yeah
sober yeah
yeah actually i stopped that for a
little while too i did stop processing
for just a second
um
just so i can get my hair clear about my
dude oh my dude and then um
like
i think
three months after that i met this uh
this
young man and um
because i was sitting out on the bench
i'm uh
i work on 11 to pick so i was sitting
out on the bus bench and i was crying
and he pulled over
and he's like you all right
like yeah i'm okay
and um
he said come on
i got in the car with him
he took me to starbucks
we went to starbucks he was like you
want something from here i'm like i
don't know nothing about those starbucks
[ __ ] this brush don't be the starbucks
but he made it so he made it so funny
you know what i'm saying
and he was like well i ordered something
for you and he got me a dragon fruit a
mango dragon fruit
bomb
that [ __ ] is bomb
um and he talked to me and i told him
everything that was going on what
happened and everything and uh
he was cool he's a square
he's a straight square
he works a nine to five which me and him
were on totally different pages when it
comes to that because he asked me about
that too he asked me why you don't work
just a regular job i had to break that
down to him
i don't do that
and uh sometimes opposites attract yeah
pretty much
he has a good job he's been working his
job for 20 over 20 something years since
he was 16 and i'm trying i'm like
flabbergasted over that
and you've been working since 16 and i
don't even want to work the [ __ ] are you
working
yeah
on my own time not on somebody else yeah
you you work hard
[ __ ]
what hours are you working
i do from
this just on certain days though so on
the weekends i'll go from 12 to 12.
the night to noon uh-huh no from noon to
midnight into midnight uh-huh and then a
lot of girls will work midnight to noon
you know i do it obviously because
everybody's out at that time i don't
want to be out when everybody else is
out
a lot of girls at work like i don't want
i don't want to be out there when the
hose is out there when i rest in the
hose out there i don't like
because you're working off hours right
so i work the opposite of everybody else
so when they out there
i'm still inside
dealing with my my my phone off my phone
so when they out there i go in when they
come out when they go in i come out
i don't it's not fun being out there
with all them because one they start
distracting you with the [ __ ]
and then they can't women out there 24
hours a day they pimps are riding around
recruiting
it's like them again get out the way
but when they see renegades out there
it's like yeah they own us i don't like
that i like being out there like that
that's frustrating to me so i work on
off hours
how does this kind of work affect you
like emotionally
um i have to be hard to do it
you do have to be hot
that's what i was getting i have not
been able to [ __ ] a man sober
since i started this [ __ ] what about
your dude
i could [ __ ] sober yeah i can't [ __ ]
my man somebody you care about you can
right
because that's my i love them that's
your heart but somebody who's a
stranger's [ __ ] i don't give a
[ __ ] how much of a rapport we get
together how much of my regular you are
i cannot [ __ ] you without being high
it's just not gonna happen
if i don't have a high you don't have no
[ __ ] no head no ass nothing you
probably won't even get a conversation
that's how it is with me and i mean
people say that's not cool
being sober [ __ ] a [ __ ] i
don't love is not cool either [ __ ]
appears not cool but still you know what
i'm saying i gotta do what i have to do
and
it's like
transitioning
i'm trying i'm i'm now trying to
stop
everything and just get into this
relationship but
it's like
if you can't take care of me the way i
take care of me with what i'm doing
then quite clearly i can't stop doing it
until you're able to financially take
care of both of us you need a guy who
can accept what you're doing i mean he
accepts it
uh all the men that i've been with have
accepted it
it's not it's not like they
can't accept it you don't have no choice
because you can't take care of me
could could a guy come into your life
and take care of you financially to to
the extent if he can do that
i'll stop home can you stop though yeah
you could you could be cool with that
lifestyle square life yes i lived the
square like for a minute
i really did somebody could square you
up yeah my first husband did
he met me as a whole
he married me
he got me straight
i stopped telling but i didn't stop
doing drugs though
but i stopped
and he was cool with that you know what
i'm saying
um but he passed away he died
i was out visiting my mother out here in
california that's how i got stuck out
here in california because my husband
passed away when i was visiting my mom
and um
i never went back home
that's how that's how i got stuck out
here already that's right um he drank
yourself today
he drink every day heavenly hill every
day
big guys gathering the drugs every
[ __ ] day
i mean when he wake up in the morning he
had a drink when he go to bed he had a
dream and he was like don't try to
change me i won't try to change you the
only thing i really want you to change
is just stop holding
we got married i
stopped he didn't try to stop me from
using my drugs and that i didn't stop
him from drinking
although he had surgery and all that
[ __ ]
um
then when he passed away i just didn't
go back home i've been out here 19 years
well a little bit over 19 years now and
it's like
i've gone through a lot in a little bit
of time and it's like amazing how fast
[ __ ] goes here you you
i've been through
way more stuff now
and learned a whole lot more stuff now
than i did back home because it's so
slow
it's not a fast pace
and
everybody back home know everybody
so you know what a person is doing it's
not a secret a lot of girls tell me
they're addicted to this life
the fast money you know a little bit
just a little bit
i'm not gonna lie a little bit yeah
should prostitution be legalized
yeah
it said
everybody said because there's something
like that a lot of men
they need this
they really need they need women like us
to keep from going off the rails
besides that because at home if they're
not getting it at home that's when they
come out here to us you know what i'm
saying
but you're not getting at home you
getting from out here in the streets
and then some men because these guys
will do something crazy right i mean and
then some men they just
actually love hoes better than like a
straight [ __ ]
because straight women are they're too
tight
they don't want to give them no booty
they don't want to give up the [ __ ]
they don't want to suck a dick
i mean come on now i mean there's
nothing wrong with what you do it's not
what you do it's how you do
do you it are we meant to be monogamous
sometimes
sometimes
sometimes i don't feel like i um
being
in a monogamous relationship is in the
cards for me i really don't i don't see
that
because at the end of the day
even the [ __ ] that i'm with
he's gonna find somebody else to [ __ ]
with too
so it's like whatever
but no i don't think we should
because everybody's [ __ ] everybody
anyway
they're just not talking about it
exactly or they hide it
i'm just i'm i'm not in the closet with
it i'm out in the open
you know saying
if now if i'm married
that's a different story i don't i don't
disrespect those those terms
marriage i don't disrespect i honor that
to the fullest extent so they'll do its
part i really honor that but just a
boyfriend girlfriend [ __ ] [ __ ] you you
go [ __ ] who you want to go [ __ ] who i
want to regardless because we don't do
it anyway
but as far as being in a marriage i
really respect that
now don't get it wrong if you're married
and uh
i'm not and you want to come see me i
will [ __ ] with you
i ain't worried about your wife because
i don't know her she ain't my people
when you were when you were a young girl
growing up did
did you see a loving relationship with
your parents
yeah my mom dad loved each other yeah he
just was abusive he was hit my mom
yeah and
that was like towards the end the ending
of that [ __ ] anyway
you know saying
they their
life was going out anyway they divorced
and all that
so
my dad passed away at a young age in his
50s
and um
my mom's still alive
i have passed don't get along with one i
love my mother to death don't get me
wrong i love my mother to death or kill
for my mama
but i do not like my mother
there's a difference god didn't say i
had to like her ass but he did say i do
have to love my mother and i actually do
love my mom just don't like her
or her ways just like she don't like me
on my ways
i talked to her i don't i've never hid
anything from my mother a day in my life
my mama know i prostitute my mama know i
use drugs she know everything that's
going on with me
not hot i've hit nothing from her
hell i didn't hide it from my kids i
told my kids i use drugs and i
prostitute you know what i'm saying
and i know they didn't want me to tell
my kids that but quite clearly
what i look like hiding from
they'll hate me more by hiding it and
trying to lie to him than for me to go
ahead and tell them the truth about
what's going on with me tell me about
your kids um
we're young
they're young um my oldest is 19.
my youngest is five no six now
um are you raising them
i used to
i used to
uh
my brother and my mom have my kids right
now
uh
and one
one of them is back home in mississippi
with my cousin
but
due to drugs
i've been out of their lives
you know seeing what in and out and
majority of time out of their lives um
i love my kids to death
we'll try to do anything for them
we'll try to do anything for them
because sometimes i can't do it you know
what i'm saying but um
it is what it is are you sending the
money or stuff like that um
used to
uh had to stop
for a minute
you know
things fell off other things come up
but um i'll get back to doing that
i'll get back to it what is the hardest
part of this lifestyle for you
having to sleep with a man that i don't
give a [ __ ] about
that's hard i've had i've seen girls
i've heard girls describe them as
cockroaches
no
i don't see it like that
i just see it as
bye bye nights
fly by nights that's all
helping you get what you want
they're helping you get what you need
right i mean without them there would be
no home without horn it'd be no tricks
so they go hand in hand regardless
so you can't be where's it all stem from
is it is it from the
you know because if there were no tricks
you'd there'd be no girls on the street
but if there were no unhappy marriages
there'd be no tricks true
true but then sometimes it's not even
that no happy marriages because a lot of
people a lot of the triggers out there
they ain't even married and they
tricking like a [ __ ]
it's just that they
their self-esteem is [ __ ] up most of
them
just like the [ __ ] that's out here
only most of ours most of
our women out here self-esteem is [ __ ]
up
that's why they home that's how
how easy it is to get them out to the
hole the younger the
they are
the easier it is to get them to go home
because they're impressionable
then the older that you are out there
home you've been doing it for so long
it's just like [ __ ] it's just another
[ __ ] day for you
so it is what it is and as far as the
the guys are concerned
most of them have a low self-esteem they
can't get a girlfriend or
they've been hurt by [ __ ] so they
just [ __ ] them now and say [ __ ] it i'll
pay this [ __ ] get me some heads and
[ __ ] or whatever and deal with it like
that that way they don't have to put
their feelings into it
but a lot of it is emotional and mental
the reason why it's all out here
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that work the
street like this
i think most of us are out here
because we're made to come out here
no it's not that a lot of us are out
here to survive
it's the oldest profession in the
[ __ ] world
the very first job there ever was was
honey
okay
and it's like to put food on your table
i don't care if it's the straightest
[ __ ] you've ever seen the most squares
[ __ ] every woman has had to put her
[ __ ] on the line to do something
there's no there's no going around it
you have had to do something
for money
point blank i don't care who you are you
can be [ __ ] uh
the holiest [ __ ] woman in the
world [ __ ] you gave up that [ __ ] for
some money
but it was to take care of your kids
whether it was to get your lights turned
back on whether you're supposed to eat
keep your roof over your head
whatever it means you then did it
pierre-point blank and there's no woman
on god's screen never they everything
say that she hasn't
but for some reason period because i
know i have
and i still do to survive
i have to
it's just the way i like period
either like it
respect it or get the [ __ ] on away from
me period
and for all y'all that don't like hoes
out there
so what we don't like you either
don't judge us we still human at the end
of the day
we just get paid
you have any regrets in your life huh do
you have any regrets in your life do i
have any regrets yeah using crack
cocaine that's the only regret i have
if you weren't
smoking crack would you be working the
streets hell no you wouldn't no
so the drug the drug the judge pushed me
towards you it drives you yeah it does
it's the only thing that make that
allows me to go and do it
the drugs is what allows me to do it
because sober
you can't date me
you can't give me the date nobody's over
is that right i don't care who it is it
could be a million dollar man you cannot
give me the data not if i'm sober
i don't do no dating silver period yet
there is no iphones or buts about it if
i'm sober you will not get none
there ain't no amount of money that can
give me to do it nothing's over
so that's how i know if i ever quit
doing drugs i'll quit holding
you to quit smoking crack
what
what would we get you just to quit
um myself
me and god that's it
i've tried a few times
i have tried a few times because i
wanted to
then a couple of times i did it because
a [ __ ] wanted me to
then i did it because my family wanted
me to
but
it just it hasn't gotten to that point
yet where
i'm done playing around with with
when you're ready you'll be ready yeah
in due time it's
trust me it's getting to that time that
i want to be done
this year it
came in on a good note i came in on the
whole track this year
sitting on the on the track
with my mother-in-law
i brought the new year's end sitting on
the show with my mother-in-law
so i already knew that right there
bringing in the new year right there
just let me know
i'm going out this new year
off the track
you're gonna quit this year yeah
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
how to protect myself and keep safe
you have to out there right how to run
listen to your instincts
yeah my good feeling
yeah but i've always had good instincts
i really haven't put myself in the
position of not
being in tune with people
so
it's like
i've always really been able to
judge people's character you've been
doing sex work since you were 14 what
what have you learned about men
um
they're all [ __ ]
all men are [ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ]
about the sweetest man on earth you sit
in an [ __ ]
it's still an [ __ ] but
i learned one thing all guys are not the
same they ain't all roaches
so majority of you are but not all of
you
yeah
it's all right though
i've
i've gotten old enough to know
the difference between
[ __ ] and [ __ ]
because a lot of men come with the og
[ __ ]
and just gonna [ __ ] you and don't want
to pay you so they just act like they
want to be your friend they want to be
this
but i
from 14 to now i've weeded out through
all that [ __ ] because i've been through
all the [ __ ]
and probably have something to come but
i've been through all the man and female
[ __ ]
that i could stand or want to ever be in
in my life
so
it's
i grew up
i grew up i finally grew up this year
this the beginning this year i finally
grew up i learned a few things
and
it's over for me it's over for me i'm
good
i'm good
i can uh stop shaking every time a
person says job
[Laughter]
i don't get so nervous no more
but
yeah i put in a couple applications
you did yeah good for you um one oh my
god i forgot to go see this
[Laughter]
oh
this will be your your exit yeah
basically
um i put one in for walmart
i put one in for um smart final
and
i got two in at um cleaning companies
so
hopefully
one of them
will look at my application and say yeah
we'll hire her
even with a little bit of experience
that she has you put away your heels
yeah they go on the shelf they're not
gonna be put away forever but they'll go
on the shelf cause i may need them one
day
all right money get funny out here and
[ __ ]
never know i might be stuck light for
you and got cut off oh [ __ ]
here we go
let me go ask everybody in the world
first can they loan me the money and let
everybody tell me no
sooner they tell me no that's it take
them [ __ ] off the shelf and put them
on let's go
it's time to get paid
all right diamond thank you so much for
talking with me no problem very
interesting
i wish you good luck this year
hopefully
i hope i'm making sure
i hope i just stop
but if i don't you'll see me back
all right thank you
you